so i was at a
mastermind with seven other
entrepreneurs and the total room
cumulatively was doing over 500 million
dollars a year in revenue and uh so this
was kind of a cool meetup of very high
level entrepreneurs
and you know everybody kind of went up
there and and shared the things that
they were doing well
and uh you know between things we're
eating and having a good time and uh
what was interesting to me is that in
the entrepreneurial world
so many entrepreneurs have all these
weird shticks about like their food and
their exercise and their hydration and
their what you know orange glasses they
wear and their finger toe shoes and
their bio hacking and just all this
weirdness but i actually came from the
fitness world and uh all that stuff is
complete make believe [ __ ] and so um
it's really good for selling people
stuff but it's complete a complete farce
so anyways i uh the whole time these
guys are sitting there and uh they're
like oh no i only eat keto and they're
so i only do intermittent fasting right
and uh and i'm sitting there listening
to them i'm like eating twizzlers and
cookies and ice cream and they're like
what the you know like what are you
doing right and by the second day they
see that i literally continue to eat
this way like an [ __ ] um
and they're like what are you what are
you doing man like how does this work
and so
between all the stuff that we talked
about business-wise um while it was
lunchtime i was like all right this is
uh this is kind of how i've been eating
for 17 years and i was in better shape
than all the guys there
and believe it or not
a bunch of those guys ended up telling
me months later that they had all gotten
in shape
based on the presentation that i gave
them
which is a different way of eating and
so
um i've been doing this for almost 20
years
i've been in shape that entire time i
have not not had a six-pack since i was
13 or 14. um and i eat ice cream every
day
yep every day um and i drink alcohol and
i eat cookies and i do all the things um
that people want to do all right and so
what i'm going to take you through is a
very special little thing that i put
together um which is actually an
adaptation of what i presented to these
guys
um at this little meetup all right so uh
buckle up and i think that you will
enjoy this
the first thing that everybody has to
understand is what body type you are and
what body type you'd like to become
right and so i kind of put this on a
little matrix of high fat low fat low
muscle high muscle so you could be you
know uh high fat low muscle and you
would have a very feminine figure right
you could have low muscle low fat and be
skin and bones you could be high fat
high muscle and just be big you could be
low fat
and high muscle which is what a
bodybuilder is and you know there's
various pieces along this curve right
once you figure out where you are let's
say you're skinny right and you want to
get uh big right then you would have a
line that you could pretty much draw
directionally to the place that you want
to go so if you're going up that way
that means you need to uh increase your
number of calories
and you need to increase your volume
those are the two things that you need
to do because if you're going in this
direction then this these are the two
directional arrows this guy and this guy
that you would need to adhere to right
so
you basically plot the same uh
hot increase calories decrease calories
decrease volume increase volume along
the same plot line that you had high fat
low fat high muscle low muscle all right
don't get too sp caught up in this i
just like to have visuals because that's
how how i think if you know where you
are and you know where you want to go
then you can know what you need to do to
get there you increase your calories and
increase your volume and there you go
here's the thing that got them all
tripped up
and then i said hey guys do you guys
want to know why all your diets are the
same and they were like uh what i was
like yeah crazy i know
and so right now
not including alcohol there's three main
macronutrients right you got protein
carbs and fat if you're eating a normal
balanced meal that's what something like
this would look like right
uh you have kind of an even distribution
of protein carbs and fat in your meal
now what happens is whenever you do a
diet right so let's say you do keto all
right well if you're doing keto all
you're doing is you're going to be
removing this orange thing and having
just you basically eliminate your carbs
and so you eat
one third fewer calories makes sense
if you have a low-fat diet you're
eliminating your fat which is this
yellow guy right and again you're eating
one-third fewer calories if you did a
portion control diet you would eat equal
amounts of the same three things but
just less of them overall and so you
would you guessed it eat fewer calories
and if you did intermittent fasting you
would go from eating three meals a day
to eating two meals a day and guess what
you would be eating fewer calories sorry
about the camera being crazy anyway so
this is the thing that's happening right
now right is that you're eliminating
calories that is what is going on in
every diet that you possibly do all
right and so all these guys get all like
oh no i do really well with low carb i
do really well with high fat you know
high low whatever it doesn't matter like
it's all horseshit it's just calories
it's all that matters okay
and so um this was driving me nuts which
is why i started making this little put
together for you guys
but this is why every other diet is the
same right and here's the here's the fun
one for you if you struggled and you had
a diet that didn't work for you here's
why let's say you did keto if you did
keto the wrong the right way it would
look like this right you would cut out
your carbs right and then that calorie
amount is eliminated from your diet and
then over time you lose weight right now
this is what a lot of people who said ah
keto didn't work for me it's like
because you started drinking butter
right you started eating rib eyes for
breakfast every day well no [ __ ] there's
a lot more calories that you took in so
the amount that you cut out did not
compensate for the amount of excess
protein and fat that you added into your
diet that ended up actually netting you
more calories than you would need right
and that's why it didn't work for you
that is why these diets don't work so
what i will tell you now is what
actually has to happen in order for it
to work uh in reality okay
so these are the only three things that
99 of people need to know in order to
figure out what they want to uh how they
wanna eat how they wanna look you just
gotta know one
how many calories you need to eat
two how many grams of protein you need
and three how much volume you need to do
i'm not gonna talk about number three
today i'm just gonna talk about one and
two because that's what 99 you need to
even think about anyways here's the
simplest way to figure out number one
now there's a million there's a million
uh little formulas that you can use here
the basic one is your body weight times
your goal very simple so if you're a 200
pound guy right and you wanted to
maintain then you'll probably be eating
between 2 600 and 3 000 calories so 200
to do
times 15 would be cool 3 000 calories
right that's if you wanted to maintain
on the high side right now let's say you
wanted to lose weight unless you wanted
to go a little bit more extreme then it
would be 200 times 10 which would be 2
000 calories very simple all right
there's a million different ways to try
and calculate this and none of them
matter because controlling what you
ingest is easy
understanding how much you expel in
calories is very hard and so it doesn't
matter anyways the thing is is step one
is you determine how many calories
you're supposed to eat based on your
goal and the thing is is if you started
this and you're like man i wanted to
lose weight and you're not losing weight
at a rate that you would find fast
enough you can always just decrease it
it's not that hard right very
straightforward so you multiply your
body weight by the the number here so
you can see here it's from 7 all the way
up to 21. if you wanted to have extreme
weight gain it'd be your body weight
times
you know a high up number over here if
you wanted to have extreme weight loss
it'd be a low number over here
and that's it right if you ever
everything in between so i said if you
wanted to have pretty fast weight loss
then you'd be your body weight times 10
right very simple now that we've done
that we go to step two you got to figure
out how much protein to eat and this is
the part that everyone gets kind of
trippy on right because i'm showing you
the whole point of this and put this
together for you and then you can have
all the ice cream and all the cookies
and all the alcohol you ever dreamed of
and still have a six pack all right
forever for good because it's my belief
that if you're if you're going to do
this right if you're going to play the
game you have to do it in a way that
you'd be able to do it forever right if
i can't do something for the rest of my
life then i don't see a point in doing
it who cares about being in shape for
eight weeks right when i want to be in
shape for the rest of my life right no
one's going to remember you for being in
shape that that time period they're
going to be like oh yeah you always
struggled with his weight and he was
always trying new crazy things wouldn't
it be nice to just solve it for good
protein uh which is the second number
here your body weight times 1 in grams
is about what you need to have for
protein per day very simple all right so
for 200 pounds then you need 200 grams
of protein now here's where it's kind of
cool you're like well and here's the
biggest life hack and possibly give you
100 grams of protein is equivalent to
one pound of lean meat
all right so if you need to have 200
grams that would be two pounds of lean
meat and so for me the world's simplest
you know diet of all time and by diet
it's like this is just how i live he
said i eat two pounds of meat a day all
right and be like that's crazy it's not
really you get used to it right and uh
you just stop eating the crap that you
probably eat right now so two pounds of
meat can be two pounds of shrimp it
could be two pounds of uh tilapia could
be two pounds up it doesn't have to be
the same thing you could have a quarter
pound of four different things you know
excuse me a half pound of four different
things uh you could have a tenderloin
you know you could have a skirt stick
you have flank steak like those are very
lean steaks uh actually not squishy
sorry flank sticks lean you could have
top round you could have uh top sirloin
like those are all very lean steaks all
of these are just very lean proteins uh
chicken breasts right there's a million
of these but the point is is that a lean
meat is a lean meat and they're all
about the same in terms of grams if you
needed to have
200 grams of protein then you'd have two
pounds of lean meat and that's what you
would eat for the day all right wait
don't worry you're like what about the
cookies and ice cream i'm gonna get
there now we have to figure out if we
know how many calories we're eating per
day and we know uh how much protein
we're eating then we need to figure out
what's left over so here's how you put
it all together one is we calculated our
calories for our goal so if we said we
wanted to lose weight we were 200 pounds
and we did 11 sure because we want to do
moderate weight loss we would eat 2 200
calories a day awesome second step
here we calculate protein for our body
weight so if we were 200 200 pounds we'd
have 200 grams of protein great which is
gonna be two pounds of lean meat simple
step three
we're going to calculate
our calories from our protein all right
so roughly
roughly
if you want to be all sciency four four
calories per gram is how many actual
calories are in a gram of protein but
when you eat a source of protein like a
chicken breast there's also some fat in
it right even when it's super lean
there's still some fat and so
what we do what i do my back of napkins
secret super method is you just multiply
it by five all right the reason i do
that is so that i can account for a
little bit of fat that's gonna be
carried along with it so if i'm gonna
have my 200 grams of protein times five
it means i'm going to eat about a
thousand calories they're going to come
from my protein sources all right great
so now what i'm going to do is i'm going
to take my step 4 my 2200 calories
subtract my thousand calories of protein
and i've got 1200 calories of whatever
the hell i want every day here's the
secret to having the body you want for
the rest of your life eating cookies
every day and making every entrepreneur
that you go to the masterminds with feel
like a [ __ ] because you have a six-pack
and you're eating ice cream and cookies
and twizzlers and all the things that
you want in this world while they are
telling you about why they're biohacking
right and why they're burning so much
fat right now except they look the same
every year here's the key you eat the
1200 calories of whatever the hell you
want and you can do it every day you can
change what you want to eat in those
1200 calories every day if you feel like
it but the key point is that the
cornerstone of the diet is that you get
enough protein in so you get your
protein in first and then you fill up to
the lid and whatever else you want now
you may find out that a white potato is
more filling than nerds ropes i would
know this from first hand but if you
don't have a compulsive need to eat
right which i don't um then you can
control yourself and eat whatever the
heck you want right i tend to not be
that hungry as a person in general and
so i like to have more appetizing foods
and i'd rather eat less of them right
some people love to have huge volumes of
food in which case you'll probably eat
more whole foods right you'll probably
have more potatoes and rice and all that
kind of stuff right
the point is is that once you just know
those two numbers how many calories you
eat how many grams of protein you have
you can eat for the rest of your life
never go on or off a diet ever again and
here's the cool part you can split up
those meals whatever way you want all
right you can eat them you can be like i
can have five meals a day you can have
three meals a day you could have one
meal a day it doesn't matter all right
crazy i know it's like it's almost like
they've been trying to sell you your
whole lives i know all right but the
reason this is so cool is that you can't
fall off right there's no like diet like
you you can eat whatever the hell you
want like it doesn't matter you want to
have ice cream every day you guys from
every day and so if you're like oh like
you can't you won't feel like you're
cheating on a cheat day because you have
ice cream every day right the best way
to get people to become obsessed with
food is to get them to restrict
themselves from doing stuff because then
they
splurge and you know do a ton of it but
if you eat ice cream today it stops
being special if you eat cookies every
day it stops being special right and so
this is how i've eaten for almost 20
years um this has been you know the the
secret behind it um and i get very tired
of seeing the entrepreneurial world get
fooled with shenanigans of stuff that
does not matter that is why i wanted to
share this with you it's also like the
number one question i get which is like
hey what do you eat every day um this is
what i've eaten every day for almost 20
years um and all i do is i adjust the
you know the goal up and down if i want
to you know if i wanted to gain weight i
would eat the same two pounds of protein
i would just have more extra calories if
i wanted to have it's you basically have
this base of protein that just protects
your muscle right and then everything
else is just variable of just how many
calories extra you want to eat and you
can eat them whatever you want i want to
make sure that i got all my little notes
here that i remembered but the big point
here is that all this stuff works
because you can't fall off right you
can't cheat because nothing is forbidden
right and
no one is immune to a calorie deficit
right if you eat nothing long enough you
will lose weight
everyone like like some people lose
weight faster or slower but everybody
loses weight in deficit that's it that's
the that's the food portion of uh of
what alex eats every day and if you're
an entrepreneur and you're like man i
wish i could you know you're obsessed
with all this biohacking and all the all
the supplements to try and uh to try and
lose lose fat faster but you're but you
look the exact same years later um then
uh it's possible that maybe the stuff
that you're doing doesn't work and it
doesn't matter
and instead you should take a page out
of this and um what's kind of funny is
that uh i know
just as much if not more about fitness
stuff than i do about business stuff but
i just haven't talked about in a very
long time and i don't want this channel
to be a fitness channel i just get
really really tired of the shenanigans
and the tomfoolery
that i see in the entrepreneurial space
around this and people speak in these
absolutes
and they're completely false and so
anyways i know that mossy nation you
guys are intelligent
and hopefully shredded and jacked in the
future and i want you to be able to
hashtag never skip dessert while also
having a six-pack
and that is why i made this video for
you so uh keep being awesome lots of
love if you enjoyed this hit sub if you
didn't love either way catch you guys
next video bye